[Musique]
Mesdames et Messieurs les
jurés comment allez-vous pour ceux qui
ne me connaissent pas je m'appelle
Monsieur
G William G jamais entendu parler de lui
sérieusement qu'est-ce qu'il a de si
spécial ce
type un procè c'est une guerre où tous
les coups sont permis je vous parle pas
d'une baston la no je vous parle deage
de cul la JeanClaude la vérité c'est que
je me suis peutre mis dans le je suis
ton avoc DEP presque ans on va'en jamais
poursuivi personne de toute ta vie ce
type a essayé de me dépouiller de mon
business il faut pas s'attendre à ce que
je reste sans rien faire il a pas perdu
un seul procès ces 12 dernières années
tu me suggères d'engager ce type comme
l'un de mes avocats entrez je vous en
prie enchanté Monsieur G j'aimerais vous
présenter Michael red qu'est-ce que ça
vous fait de travailler avec des Noirs
je crois que j'ai quelques préjugés vous
connaissez pas mon équipe moi c'est
Chris dasan reg Douglas
messieur il nous attaque en justice il
nous attaque en justice on est un group
qui pèse dem milliard de dollars combien
vous voulez obtenir 8 millions il y a
pas ass de fric 100 millions de
dollars c'est qui le guignol qui l'a
engagé comme
[Musique]
avocat vous êtes un battant c'est quoi
votre motivation typ voulu s'prendra la
chose la plus importante dans ma vie
pouvoir transmettre quelque chose à mes
petits enfants mets un peu de
[Musique]
musique elle
s'appelle MAJ de sa promo à la de droit
de Harvard il m'a dit qu'on lui avait
donné un surnom au bureau le python ne
vous habituez pas trop à ce que je sois
gentil avec vous monsieur Gary parce
qu'une fois que le procès aura
commencé je vous
détruirai la vérité messieurs c'est
qu'on a une chance sur un million de
gagner vous devez me faire confiance ok
j'ai j'ai peut-être trouvé quelque chose
qu'est-ce que ça fait d'être un petit
entrepreneur de pompe funèbre sans
envergure au bord du dépôt de
bilan imagine que je gagne
et que je dé sooive toutes ces personnes
votre priorité est de transformer ce
procès en circle bruillant ma vie est en
jeu n d'un chien je suis au
courant ça vous a déjà gé dire
chose votre cul cette objection
V attendez arrêtez-vous là pas laisser
poteau n diviser allez tout le monde
[Musique]
recule see we
go